operation finale it's a very heavy movie
it's very there's a lot of history
behind it and I'm wondering it was there
ever a moment for either of you
we're either pre-production onset after
after filming where it sort of hate you
or the the weight of it hit you with it
you really felt the history of the
entire thing well we've been talking
about the first scene that we all shot
as a group together was with Sir Ben
Kingsley as Eichmann in the first
interrogation scene
and I think all of us sat there and and
and we had not had a ton of time with
Sir Ben before that moment and he came
on set as Eichmann and we shot that
interrogation see and I think all of us
felt this feeling of like wow this
happened and these were real people and
this is a a truly this was a probably an
incredibly impactful moment in all of
these people's lives and and let alone
the history of of the world on this sort
of the flip side of that is there ever a
moment where it is Ben Kingsley and you
have to look at him with such dislike
you have to be like but still Ben
Kingsley in that costume did that did I
ever make it hard for you to I think at
the moment we saw Ben Kingsley getting
into the room of the we were like we're
reading we were reading the script how
caught at the table reading yes yeah and
in the minute he came and set they're
concentrating on his work we understand
that this is for us he was Eichmann in
that moment you don't and he was not
involved with us he was very separate
for separated he was with himself like a
monk for three months and we were all
together having family the Mossad team
and he was with it with himself and just
working and working and working
concentrating on his job and when you
see this amazing actor you understand
that he's there he's in his zone and
don't bother him and he's Eichmann from
now on mm-hmm it's interesting that you
mentioned that the rest of you were sort
of bonding and having
fund is where their conversations of how
you wanted to that dynamic to be as a
team because this is a really team
oriented movie it's very close set it's
you guys in that house I'm wondering
what kind of conversations you all had
as a cast and outside I think it just
happened you know it's the energy of us
as as the or Aniak and and Michael Aaron
off and an Oscar we were a group of
people who work together and we became
like a good friends out out outside the
set but also in the set and use you see
that and you understand that they are
very close people and and we shot we did
shoot in the the safe house where they
kept Eichmann for the ten days between
when they captured him to when they were
able to get him out of the country we
shot in this one house and this one
location and it was this feeling of
people becoming very close and that
people becoming very claustrophobic
feeling tired of figuring out Lior and I
almost fought numerous times and we
might today to day but it really but it
was you know and also it within our cast
we had Israelis French Germans Americans
which is what Israel really was like in
1960 because people were coming from all
over the world to this new nation-state
and you see everybody come together it
was it was a really exciting and for me
the opportunity to work with all these
different people from all over from
other places that I had never been able
to work with was was a very exciting
part of the film amazing
you